being an executive producer also does
allow me to do that like sit and chat
with all the actors and get their sense
of what they want and what they're
feeling and what's going on and we can
all work together to make the show the
best I can do it wasn't so bad at all
yeah she fired me briefly but then and
it was we worked it all out in burden of
truth Kristin plays a corporate lawyer
who let's just say isn't exactly welcome
back into her home town nobody wants you
here how does it look you look like you
from no one in the 10 part series her
character tries to crack a case of why
young girls are becoming mysteriously
sick Johanna Hanley attorney for bore
Doc's William Crawford Crawford &
Associates we went to school together
the legal jargon becomes increasingly
difficult yeah yeah yeah the 4 a.m.
takes for a little model-t it's okay
I've had a long day see I'm terrible at
it
that's not true listen some days I'm
terrible at it and some days I'm okay at
it but I find it really difficult I
really do
your honor an injunction before a full
hearing on the merits would cause my
clients significant reputational harm
the drama was shot in Winnipeg which
meant co-star Peter Mooney actually did
get to return to his hometown but the
Manitoba City kind of freaked out star
Slade's
thumbs I felt like actually weird like I
was been like on another planet or
something cuz it was so flattening and
actually made me uncomfortable
yeah and icy hills I get very panicked
[Laughter]